you want to say pushback go read my
instagram comments right now after i
posted this the federally insured
student loan program is stupid and it
needs to stop
now we the people need to quit letting
congress insure loans in our name to put
young people so deeply in debt they
can't breathe
i'm not against education i'm against
stupidity all the comments are so you
don't want people to go to college
and you can't afford college you're old
man you don't know anything about the
cost of college
the comments are full of stupid people
and
there's there's a rock star right there
who just did it that's what i'm saying
it's pretty freaking amazing
amazing so you should comment on
instagram if you're stupid
okay their comments are stupid they are
not stupid yes
both would be true both would be true
we were rudely interrupted by the
network's need to make a profit around
here with those commercials and so i
want to continue that discussion
um the answer to the equation is simply
this
okay young page uh as
absolute rock star and uh is an example
of thousands of people
that we have met over the years that
have gone to college
debt-free okay now what do we tell
people anthony o'neil's book debt-free
degree
covers this and the first thing that you
have to do
is you have to stop saying
to yourself and for sure to your young
people america
that the only way to go to college
because college is so
expensive that you
only way to go to college as a student
loan and to do away with a student loan
debt program would mean to do away with
education which is absolutely
asinine and wrong so you have to stop
saying that first
and then how could you say that well you
can say that with the proof
that's in the pudding and the elements
that you need to do to go to college
debt-free r scholarships that's what
she's doing well it's choosing a school
you can afford first and foremost
um scholarships and grants working
i mean there's there's there's many
elements but i think that that very
first step though
well the one before that one was that
you have to decide yourself
i'm not gonna do this like i'm not going
into debt for it so now what are my
options
and when you do that then reality starts
to play in okay maybe i go to a
community college for the first year or
two my school selection is key
maybe you stay in state and go to a
public university paige
still freaking went to a private school
thirty seven thousand dollars a year
but had the scholarships to do it and
worked
and never she never paid thirty seven
thousand no she chose her school based
on where she could get scholarships
and that she could afford it so you go
to a school
that's doing that abilene christian in
this case which i've got a good friend
that graduated from there
a couple of matter of fact and
you also can go to an in-state school
you also can go to community college
and you don't have to go across state
lines and pay three times the tuition
for basically the same education because
you went across the state line
now some adjoining states sometimes will
give you in-state tuition because
they're trying to attract students
across the state line yeah
um and espec particularly students with
good grades now the other thing was she
had a good grades let me tell you also
what else she had great parents
you know i know she had great parents
she's articulate
and poised and confident she is
working hard 35 hours
a week she did her studies
when she was in high school and wasn't
turned out to run loose in anarchy
we know that because she got academic
scholarships
okay you don't get those without putting
in the work
they don't look at people and go oh
you're smart
they go you did the work and you got the
grades
and you're smart that's how academic
scholarships happen
so there was discipline in that
household yeah absolutely
well and yeah and into her credit i'm
like she's 21.
she's a rock star and just absolutely
killed it so it is it's just that's why
i wanted to keep her on the phone so i'm
like it's just proof like this shows you
it's stories we hear all the time
but not everyone hears them so when you
have someone like that on the phone
you're like okay
tell me exactly what you did what was
your situation because oh my god
and i honestly thought she was going to
go to a public school most people that
worked their way through
the fact she even went to a freaking
private school thirty seven thousand
dollars a year and still did it with
scholarships awards never paid more than
16.
it's amazing for the 37. that's the deal
she worked them because they wanted her
there
and you believe me if you're college you
want people like paige there
yeah they work at getting you there so
parents
parent these are 18 year olds
17 year olds 15 year olds that are
preparing for college
they need to get their little butts in
gear and get ready
and not wander out half drunk out of
their senior year
trying to figure out what well i'm just
going to go to college like the guy
called me up
he's like i don't know what i'm going to
do my daughter told me she's going to
this expensive school and i'm like well
see that's where you get confused in my
household
my teenagers didn't tell me stuff i told
them stuff
my daughter told me where she's going
with my money how's that work
that don't work and so you know we
didn't do that at our place
you know we didn't i mean we discussed
it we had a conversation but we all kind
of knew where you were going to school
in state where we could pay for it and
pay cash for it and not overpay for it
and you know the young lady had called
me up a few months ago from south
carolina she wants to go to ole miss
and pay five times four times the
tuition
because she's out of state instead of
going to south carolina in state
why i asked her the houses
around ole miss it's such a pretty town
it is very pretty
no it's a pretty town
you're killing me here oxford is it
oxford it's a gorgeous town
and for for a few hundred dollars you
can visit
once a year and stay a week i know you
don't have to pay five times or four
times the tuition to go out of state
dumber than a rock unbelievable
now and i'm paying the bill because she
got a federally insured student loan
insured by a taxpayer
but if if nor south carolina girl want
to go to ole miss and she had
scholarships and had the money
to go go you're not mad at that go but
please don't make your decision based on
how pretty the town is
geez it's not how you pick your
education that's just not good critical
thinking skills
i i i was just not an art class oh my
god
it's an education study
because well okay okay it's an anathema
to me that we don't think about
education i know but listen
this is where this is where your point
about the parents being parents is huge
because what your 18 year old sees
their perspective is right here right
their perspective is who's going to what
school
are they going to do it for a sorority
or fraternity are they doing intramural
like
like that is their world and you parents
are decades ahead of them and so to
bring that reality to the 18 year old is
what is key so yes you're not
you're not picking a school based on how
pretty the town is you're not doing it
based on friends it is
what is smart financially and where you
can get a good education if you're
paying for it
so doing all that because what's going
to happen is that 18 year old's
perspective is going to go through four
years five years of school
hopefully fourth they do it in town in
time and then they're going to be
five years out looking back and have
zero one year out
no regrets the people that we hear the
regrets from are the 18 year olds who
didn't have conversations with their
parents they really just signed up for
whatever school they wanted to sign up
for
then they're a year out with tens of
thousands of dollars of student loans
that they're having to pay back and
they're not able to do things that they
want to do
they're stuck because of that so it is
completely frozen it's all they see
so her seeing the pretty town that's all
she sees so like
having people in her life who i'm sure
you did on the call from
i was nice that was nice i was i was
i had to breathe but i was not but it's
true but like that's the thing is like
and i even learned in a book recently
i'm going to totally butcher this so all
you psychologists out there can correct
me
but even like the frontal lobe of your
brain like fully does not become mature
until like 25 or something so they're
making
talks about it they're making these
decisions that are going to affect them
for
so long and so that's what you have to
look at you are a loving parent
by having these conversations and
talking about them here's one okay
out of all the successful people i know
and i am privy to run around with some
uber successful people
i have never met a soul that said i am
successful
because i graduated from a college that
i followed my girlfriend to
not once i selected the college i'm
going to
based on my girlfriend is going there
and that led to my success in life
i'll go a step further you have probably
never met someone that says i am
successful because of where i went to
school even
that's true that's true but they often
tell
stories you know when you get a little
older of regret
for the stupid butt stuff that we have
all done yeah and
i've got a phd in d d umb i've got a
whole list of stupid butt stories of
things i've done
and and you know but following your
girlfriend to college would be on the
list
you don't go to college because your
girlfriend is going there
i'm sorry that unless you can be stupid
even if you can pay for it this is not a
recreational activity
it's an education it's an education
this is not how you select your field of
study
and the place that you're going to do it
and what you're going to pay for it
and this is how we have a student loan
crisis is we're financing this crap
the number of people when we did
borrowed future that we interviewed for
that podcast
that used their student loans to buy
cars while they were in college
was innumerable yep for sure well the
amount of money that goes to lifestyle
is it it's yes they live in an apartment
with a skylight and a jacuzzi and they
play
beer pong on their time off on my nickel
because i guarantee these student loans
because i'm an idiot as a taxpayer
and i allowed congress to continue to do
this we're
we're this is who we're guaranteeing
loans for argument
just nothing none of you in a fruitcake
so go to a college you can afford
work work it's not a dirty word it's not
a four letter word
you're not gonna die from it right
before you die you'll pass out work
it's okay work
work go to a college you can afford and
get scholarships
parents parent this is the dave ramsey
show